you
can ask anyone you want
and they will tell you that they are
sick
and tired of fighting for justice
people of color and members of the lgbt
community
are tired of carrying the burden of
speaking up
and stepping up even when they're being
silenced
and pushed back down and white allies
and cis allies are tired too
tired of being told they're doing it
wrong
or that it isn't even their place to
show up at
all this fatigue
is impacting all of us and in fact
i believe we won't succeed until we
approach
justice in a new way
i grew up in the middle of the civil
rights movement
in the segregated south as a
five-year-old girl i was
very interested in ballet it seemed to
be the five-year-old girl thing to do in
the 1960s
my mother took me to a ballet school
you know the kind of school that had
teachers that talked about your gifts
and talents knowing that you'd never be
a ballerina
when we arrived they said nicely
that they did not accept negroes
we got back in the car as if we were
just leaving a grocery store that was
out of orange juice
we said nothing just drove to the next
ballet school they said
we don't accept negroes
well i was confused and i asked my
mother
why they didn't want me and she
said well they're just not smart enough
to accept you right now and they don't
know how excellent you are
well i didn't know what that meant
but i was sure it wasn't good because i
could see it in my mother's eyes
she was angry
and it looked like she was on the verge
of tears
well i decided right then and right
there
that ballet was dumb
you know i had lots of experiences like
that along the way
but as i got older i started to get
angry and not just angry at the outright
racism and injustice
i was angry at people that stood by and
didn't say anything
like why didn't the white parents in
that ballet school
say uh that's wrong let that little girl
dance
or why why didn't the
white patrons in the segregated
restaurant say hey that's not right
let that family eat well it didn't take
me long to realize that racial injustice
wasn't the only place that people in the
majority
were staying quiet when i'd sit in
church and hear some homophobic comment
being disguised as something scriptural
i'd say
i'm sorry why aren't the heterosexual
churchgoers disrupting this nonsense
or in a room
filled with boomers and gen xers
who started degrading their millennial
colleagues is being spoiled
lazy and overconfident i'd say i'm sorry
why isn't someone my age saying stop
[Music]
stereotyping
i was used to standing up on issues like
this
but why wasn't everyone else
my fifth grade teacher mrs mcfarlane
taught me that justice requires
an accomplice not just
anyone will do she said
we need unlikely allies
if we want to see real change happen
and for those of us experiencing
injustice
up front we need to be willing to accept
the help
because when we don't change
takes too long i mean imagine if
heterosexual and gay people had not come
together under the banner of marriage
equality
or what if president kennedy just wasn't
interested in the civil rights movement
most of our major movements in this
country
might have been delayed or even dead
if it weren't for the presence of
unlikely allies
when the same people speak up in the
same ways they've always spoken up
the most we'll ever get are the same
results over
and over again you know
allies often stand on the sidelines
waiting to be called up
but what if unlikely allies led out
in front of issues like what if black
and native american people stood in
front of immigration issues
or what if white people
led the charge to end racism
or what if men led the charge
on pay equity for women
or what if heterosexual people stood
in front of lgbtq issues
and what if able-bodied people advocated
for people living with disabilities
you know we can stand up for issues
weigh
in and advocate even when it seems like
the issue has nothing to do with us
and actually those are the issues that
are most compelling
and sure people will have no idea why
you are there but that's why those of us
facing injustice must be willing to
accept the help
you know we have to fight injustice with
a consciousness of grace
when white guys stand up to fight for
the liberation of black and brown people
black and brown people will have to be
willing to accept their help
and i know that's complicated but this
is collective work and it requires
everyone to be all in
one day when i was at kindergarten our
teacher
introduced us to this beautiful tall
white lady named miss ann
i thought she was the prettiest white
lady i'd ever seen
well if i can be honest with you i think
it was the first time we'd ever seen a
white lady in our school
ever miss ann stood in front of us and
she said
she was going to start teaching ballet
classes
right there at our school and that she
was
proud to be our dance teacher
it was unreal
all of a sudden i didn't think ballet
was dumb anymore
[Music]
you see what i know now is miss anne
was fully aware that the white ballet
schools
would not accept black girls she was
incensed by that
so she came to the black neighborhood to
start teaching the dance classes herself
and you know it took love and courage
for her to do that
and where there was no justice
she just built it
we all survived because we stood on the
shoulders of our black
ancestors we all
thrived because miss anne was an
unlikely ally
you know when you add your voice
and your actions to situations that you
don't think involve you
you actually inspire others to do the
same
miss anne inspired me to always be on
the lookout
for situations that weren't about me
but where i saw injustice and inequality
happening
anyway i hope she inspires you
too because to win the fight
for equity we will all
need to speak up and stand up
we will all need to do that and we will
all need to do that
even when it's hard and even when we
feel out of place
because it is your place
and it is our place
justice counts on all of us
thank you